a function and I'm gonna speak about it
in very abstract terms right now is
something that will take an input it
will take an input and it'll munch on
that input and look at that input will
do something that input and based on
what that input is it will produce a
given a given output so what is an
example of a function so I could have
something like f of f of X and X tends
to be the variable most used for an
input into the function and the name of
a function tends to be f tends to be the
most used variable but we'll see that
you can use others but we could have f
of X is equal to is equal to let's say x
squared if if X is even and let's say it
is equal to X plus 5 if X is if X is odd
so what would happen if we input 2 into
this function and the way that we would
denote inputting 2 is that we would want
to evaluate F of 2 this is saying let's
input 2 into our function f and
everywhere we see this X here this
variable you can kind of use as a
placeholder let's replace it with our
input so let's see if 2 is even do 2
squared if 2 is odd do 2 plus 5 well 2
is even so we're going to do 2 squared
so in this case f of 2 is going to be 2
squared or 4 now what would F of F of 3
be well once again everywhere we see
this variable we'll replace it with our
input we'll replace it with our input so
f of 3 so 3 squared if 3 is even 3 plus
5 if 3 is odd well 3 is odd so it's
going to be 3 plus 5 it is going to be
equal to 8 now you might say okay that's
a neat salad this was kind of an
interesting way to define a function a
way to kind of munch on these numbers
but you know I could have done this with
traditional equations in some ways
if you allowed me to use the squirrely
bracket thing what what what can a
function do that maybe my traditional
toolkits might have not been as
expressive about well you could even do
a function like this you could have an
let me let me not use F and X anymore
just to show you that the notation is
more general than that so I could say H
of a is equal to is equal to the the
next largest largest number number that
starts with the same letter the same
letter as variable a now says as
variable a and we're gonna assume that
we are dealing in English so given that
what is H of what is H of two going to
be well two starts with a T what's the
next largest number that starts with a T
well it's going to be it's going to be
equal to three now what would H of I
don't know let's think about this what
would H of H of eight be equal to well
eight starts with an e the next largest
number that starts with an e so it's not
nine ten it would be it would be 11 and
so now you see it's a very very very
general tool this function is that this
box this H function that we just defined
will look at it will look at the letter
that the the number starts with in
English and then so it's doing this
really really really really wacky thing
now not all functions have to be this
wacky in fact you have already been
dealing with functions you have seen
things like you have seen things like Y
is equal to X plus 1 this can be viewed
as a function we could write this as Y
is a function of X which is equal to X
plus 1 if you give as an input as you
give as an input so let me write it this
way so for example when we could when x
is 0 we could say f of 0 is equal to
well you take 0 you add
it's equal to one F of two is equal to
two you've already done this before
you've done things where you said look
let me make a table of X let me take and
and put our Y's there when x is 0 Y is 1
when X is 2 I'm sorry this was when X is
I mean a little mistake where F of 2 is
equal to 3 and you've done this before
with tables where you say look x and y
when x is 0 Y is 1 when X is 2 y is 3 so
this you might say well what was the
whole point of using the function
notation here to save f of X is equal to
X plus 1 and the whole point is to think
in these more general terms for
something like this you didn't really
have to in introduced function notations
but it doesn't hurt to introduce
function notations because it makes it
very clear that the function takes an
input takes my X and in this definition
it munches on it it says ok X plus 1 and
then it produces 1 more than it so here
whatever the input is the output is 1
more than that original function now I
know what you're asking all right well
what is not a function then well
remember we said a function is something
that takes an input and produces only
one possible output for that given input
so for example something like and let me
look at a visual way of thinking about a
function this time or a relationship I
should say so let's say that's our
y-axis and this right over here is our
x-axis and let me let me draw a circle
here that has radius let me draw a
circle here that has radius 2 so it's a
circle of radius 2 this is negative 2
this is positive 2 this is negative 2 so
my circle it's centered at the origin it
has radius 2 so that's my best attempt
at drawing at drawing the circle we fill
it in so this is a circle the equation
of a circle of this circle is going to
be x squared plus y squared is equal to
the radius squared is equal to 2 squared
or it's equal to 4 so the question is is
this relationship between x and y here
I've expressed it as equation here I've
visually drawn all of the X's and
that satisfy this equation is this
relationship between x and y a function
and we can see visually that it's not
going to be a function you pick a given
X let's say X is equal to 1 let's say X
is equal to 1 there's two possible Y's
that are associated with it this Y up
here and this Y down here we can even
solve for that by looking at the
equation when X is equal to 1 we get 1
squared plus y squared is equal to 4 1
plus y is equal to Y squared is equal to
4 or subtracting 1 from both sides Y
squared is equal to 3 or Y is equal to
the positive or the negative square root
of 3 this right over here is the
positive square root of 3
and this right over here is the negative
square root of 3 so this situation this
relationship where I inputted a 1 into
my my little box here and associated
with the one I associate both a positive
square root of 3 and a negative square
root of 3 this is not this is not a not
a function I cannot want associate with
my input to different outputs I can only
have one output for a given input